well lawmakers on both sides of the
aisle say the end of title 42 could
produce quote catastrophic results
including texas lieutenant governor dan
patrick he joins me now
here's uh something from the majorcas
and becerra these are of course biden
administration cabinet secretaries if
the cdc were to rescind its title 42
order at this time border patrol
facilities and local communities would
be forced to absorb at least double the
current number of migrants likely with
catastrophic results so that was the
letter that they had out there and i'm
assuming that you are very concerned
about this especially for your agents
exactly dana and our agents put their
lives on the line every day as bill's
story just showed to save other people
is this the way the bind administration
wants people to come to america zipped
up in a duffel bag in a car that's on
fire he doesn't give a damn about the
lives of the people who are crossing
this border not them he doesn't care
about americans you know he has walked
back and his administration has walked
back just about everything he says will
he walk back this policy on ending title
42 i doubt it you know in the old days
elvis used to say tcb taking care of
business bine's version of that is gcv
green card
citizenship and voting bill and dana
here are the numbers based on the 2
million plus we apprehended last year on
the border and the 2.5 million we may
get or more this year over the biden
first four years we will apprehend about
10 million people crossing the border we
think we get one out of every three so
that's another 20 million that's 30
million people that is for
new york city's four new york cities
coming into this country he wants to
give them green cards because they have
to be able to work then he wants to give
them citizenship because that's next so
they vote and keep democrats in power
that's what this is about
green card citizenship voting 10 million
people to stay in power and take over
this country and lieutenant governor let
me ask you about the drug seizures as
well because seas at the border meth
if you just look at this in 2020 it was
172 000 pounds and in 2021 182 000
pounds and we know that this is going up
all across the board for fentanyl
cocaine as well and
the overdose deaths in texas if you look
at these numbers just quickly i know
that you know them but just for the
viewers to see here that it's gone up
dramatically an 18 increase and that's a
lot of heartache
it's a lot of heartache a lot of death a
lot of young people particularly
who are dying long before they should
it's becoming one of the top killers for
young people in this country again the
biden administration and i can't say
this more clearly he doesn't care he
cannot be this naive you know you talked
earlier in the day that putin sees
what's going on around the world that
he's really not protected biden must
watch television sometime he must see
these stories he must read something or
is his is his administration keeping him
in the dark as they allege the putin
administration is keeping him in the
dark i seriously doubt it biden knows
what's going on i cannot say this any
stronger he doesn't care about the lives
of people he only cares about achieving
a political victory and that's giving 10
million 20 million 30 million people
citizenship in the first four years in
office it may take several years because
some of those are under 18 it will take
them old enough to become citizens so
that they can add 30 million voters to
the roles four new york cities will come
into this country under his first four
years in office and in texas we're
overrun but they're coming to a city in
a town near you in every state every
sheriff in every county in america is a
border county sheriff because they're
coming everywhere and dana and bill we
normally spend about a half a billion a
year on border security this year i've
authorized along with the governor and
the legislature nearly three and a half
billion and it's going up right and
those are those that should be going for
texas projects not the federal
government's job on border uh we hear
you lieutenant governor dan patrick
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now